attention il s'agit
[Musique]
d'unouis
maisuxof viux
[Musique]
jamb
Jie dans son bagaz à fa allez
onoyon le patron s'appelle
Bruno il a de la graiss plein
les de gros points noirs sur le quand
Bruno fait le menu et le SER tu as les
premières douleurs au dert lesestomac
genou qui demande pardon les comm de
nous von
les rotules de grand-mère c'est
duur à côté du R pom vapeur si avant
d'entrer il reste une molaire un conseil
tu la laisses au
[Musique]
vestiay le pon s'appelle
brun dans qu le plus doux tu risques pas
d'entendre miaou des greffiers mignons
il y en a plus B ils sont tous Deven TER
duun Gier qui voulait à tout prix du
gibier il chut avant de sucer les autes
les moustaches Eno sur le
[Musique]
Cary le patron s'appelle
bruneo il envoie des
postillons ça fait des yeux dans le
bouillon sois prudent prends bien garde
au fromage son Cambert a eu le
retournage avant de l'approcher je te
jure que tu es ou alors c'est que tu as
de la
sinusite comme Runo a un gros
panarie le mcin a prescrit
panarie mais subretissement entamenant
l'assette il le glisse au fond dans la
blanquetteyons le patron s'appelle
[Musique]
brun la gueule de bout il sagit d'un CR
où les mecs pardessus le
CAL se Rin la cloison au chef maison
uners pas pitié
les cet endroit est tellement
sympathique qu' a déjà tout Paris qui
rpplique un petit peu déçu pas être
invité ni filmé par les
[Musique]
actualitéy le patron s'appelle
Bruno allez vite le voir
avant achète la Tour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'Argent